hey can i sounds it going happy
Superbowl Sunday I can't believe it's
Super Bowl again and as you can tell I'm
wearing a Steelers Jersey with my name
on it I am a Steelers fan and you know
what that means that means I don't
really care very much about the Super
Bowl this year well they do care about a
Super Bowl snacks is this I think like
Mike Island is a little dirty from the
last video I made I forget what I made
last it I ended up spring oil all over
my camera who knows I'm a slob chuckling
you too so today we're gonna be making
some cupcakes I've had this in my pantry
for quite a while its Reese's peanut
butter and chocolate cupcakes there's
basically peanut butter fill two
cupcakes and I really just needed some
sort of football excuse to make them so
I'm gonna make it kind of like some
football themed cake I don't know what's
gonna happen I have no idea all I know
is I'm making these and I'm going to
make them edible so we are going to need
this box some other stuff okay no yeah
well okay if you're just joining me for
the first time ever welcome I'm Justine
I try to make everything in a blender I
think it's time I get a new Vitamix I
think I should treat yo'self
you've never made a cake or anything in
a blender before the first thing that
you want to do is basically put all of
the wet ingredients in first to a this
one-third vegetable this is canola oil
the same thing it's vegetable oil it
says it's good for your heart
[Music]
two thirds no it was one-third
two-thirds cup water
[Music]
it's right in front of my face right in
front of my face 2/3 cups of water 1/3
crop full things are really heating up
now speaking of heating up free baby
let's see what's in here
cupcake mix says so right there I'm to
blend this up nice and tight to get it
right
yes I bought a bunch of new spatulas so
I'm pretty excited about using them this
one looks like it's got a spatula inside
of a spatula it kind of looks like a
fish we tell you what you guys can find
a lot of really cool baking things at
the craft store okay well those look
like they're ready we got our baking
cups to make things easy I'm not sure
how much to put in these I feel like
every time I do anything I mess it up
about 2/3 for blender I've got a half a
cupcake stuck in here
oops you look like you might need a
little more so I guess it's time to put
these in the oven 21 to 26 minutes hey
Google set a timer for 21 minutes all
right
21 is it dirty no cool I want me to
clean up my mess and then we're going to
start making the peanut butter filling
oh that's gonna be delicious
all right we're back I sort of cleaned
up there's stuff everywhere but that's
how we do we need 2 tablespoons of
butter softened not melted that's not
soft that sounds not good that's boiling
that butter is boiling I did some
upgrading oh wow how did you see that
incredible pour one kiss two three four
we're gonna use this incredible a hand
mixer and how those cupcakes like
perfection Wow
here's our filling mix just open that up
oh that smells absolutely incredible
whoa whoa whoa whoa
that just got absolutely everywhere this
thing's a piece of crap I need to get a
better one leave me some comments and
suggestions on what hand mixer to get
because this thing sucks these look so
good oh my gosh I'm so excited about
this Reese's are like my favorite thing
ever
um racy cops put them in the freezer
froze and tastes so good filling in a
pastry bag place bag and tall glass of
filling that glass is not very tall it
is the tallest glass that I get well it
looks like I have to pin a cup full
we're back and the cupcakes are here
before me just magically and they're
actually still very very warm so I'm not
sure if I should just fill them now or I
don't know I think I'm just gonna fill
them you got
this so gross I don't know how far to
stick it I don't know if anything's
gonna happen but
and yeah I think something happened oh
yeah it's going in looks like they're
all fooled
so I guess I'll just try to do one of
the time up here maybe ice our first one
well this looks so good okay well it's
not like the best thing I've ever iced
but it's definitely not the worst that
seems to be a common theme not the best
but not the worst
look at these magically iced cupcakes
I'm incredibly impressed at how well I
did if I do say so myself
like these look pretty good so let's
start decorating I mean that's really
what we're here for right
yeah that looks mediocre but you get it
oh that looks just beautiful that's for
Super Bowl 51 you get the point this is
grass that I'm putting on this one if
you can't tell you use this whole thing
this entire container of green on this
one cupcake so now I should probably put
some stripes down it cuz it's gonna be
like the various yard lines cool of what
we've got going on here next oops
there's a flag on the field what
happened is there a penalty is there a
penalty this is a flag on the field I'm
like running out of things to do so
loving what I've done with the voice boo
that's a little bit the fields that got
a little muddy so this one didn't really
turn out very well
but I'm gonna I'm gonna try to salvage
it look at this grass oh god no this
looks stupid this looks so dumb this
looks so stupid this is really not
working very well I think I should just
maybe stop decorating or no one's gonna
want to eat my creations
this is awful well since I'm just about
done I guess this is a great time to ask
you guys who do you want to win the
Super Bowl Patriots or Falcons actually
you know I'm going for the Falcon we've
got one last cupcake here and I decided
to save this one because this is a very
very very special cupcake this one is
for Tom Brady and we're gonna call this
the deflate cake here Tom this one's for
you baby
good luck at the Super Bowl don't let
Tom near your balls
well thanks for watching I'm not too
estatic about my results but I'm also
not too upset you might have to do a
little bit of explaining to my guests
I'll be posting a Super Bowl vlog so
you'll get to see what everybody thinks
of them so see you later
happy Super Bowl no I gotta clean up a
lot of mess so this is a behind the
scenes of a cooking video we've got mess
mess mess mess
camera camera monitors so I can see
what's going on and just more mess just
a lot blob mess we've got batteries
charging non-stop yeah this is it
[Music]
Why What I am so irresponsible and
before you guys criticize me yeah I'm
gonna say all the terrible things about
myself I'm an idiot I am the careless
I'm reckless accidents happen